I don't think there's been another
person that's like Dennis Rodman if you
think about what Rodman was doing like
Rodman was doing [ __ ] did still taboo
now back before people if you knew what
the [ __ ] it was Rodman was dressing in
drag right this is a black man lipstick
lipstick wedding dress dying is hair
crazy
we're in leather pants like this is a
black man in the [ __ ] 90s doing this
right now if you're a rock star you're
one of these like white rocker dudes who
like banks is [ __ ] like bandmates but
also is like straight kinda like it's
not that crazy we're talking about black
man in sports what I do is in the 90s
did not do that no one did that barely
yeah barely now in the 90s
I didn't you just never ever saw it now
if you're in New York you'll see that
[ __ ]
oh I don't think even in New York and
the villagey to seeing that no I mean
you might from some actual gay guys like
this guy so Dennis Rodman is out here he
is completely unbelievable in his antics
Yeah right like he's dating Madonna I
don't think people understand what that
means
Madonna was at that time the biggest
artist in the world probably late 90s -
yeah she's also like Britney Spears when
Britney was in her prime also it's not
late 90s he's dating Madonna when he's
with the Spurs so made 95 91 or 92 nice
Pistons tell you 93 94 somebody no 91 92
he got the Rings maybe 93 okay so MIT
MIT MIT he's dating [ __ ] Madonna
people Donner said Madonna is massive
one of the biggest artists in a history
- game right right yeah
Takashi 6-9 barely dating an Instagram
thoughts sure right like this guy's
dating the biggest artist one of the
biggest artists of all time and the big
artists at the time right and bangers is
not the same as five rings three after
he started acting it's hard making it
hit no no it's hard making it here and I
hear what you're saying but I also hear
what you're saying things to it but
then he dates when he's with the Bulls
Carmen Electra I don't think people
realize I'm like there was that [ __ ]
she was that [ __ ] was she she was like
becoming that [ __ ] not probably helped
her because you wanted them [ __ ]
she was already Prince's girl she
started out as princes girl oh really
yeah okay I thought they came after no
she started out as princes girl then she
got an MTV I think she took over for
Jenny McCarthy was singled out maybe
some issue just became sex she was sex
personified yeah right so you go from
Madonna to the next sexiest [ __ ] right
you're out partying all of them right
okay
dressing whoever the [ __ ] you want nail
polish tattoos liberabit bellybutton
ring you define all these cultural
standards of masculinity while you're in
this sport that's supposed to personify
masculinity yeah all forgive it because
you don't care what [ __ ] think
about you maybe you do deeply do care
and that's why you're rejecting it but
doesn't right right all the while
winning [ __ ] rings right like
defensive MVP best the best rebounder
ever in the history of the game people
forget about the Spurs season you know
he averaged 17 rebounds a game in his
birth season
wait for it didn't even start all the
games he didn't even start every game
you had Duncan and Robinson on team
talking on our team yes he was yes he
was look it up I think so yeah oh God
don't get it Robinson and see if they
were on the team Duncan God you Robinson
was Robinson didn't like Rodman that was
a big point of contention sure I think
Duncan got drafted like 97 98 sound like
that night look at what year uh Tim
Duncan was on the anyway point is 97 are
you sure yeah yeah man anyway I was
reading some article that said he has a
one thing yeah you got to take back what
you said about not one person Robbie
that's what I was going for that's what
I was going to you know I was I said I
don't want to hear anything about any
other any other player but I forget how
[ __ ] interesting everyone on that
was I mean I mean everyone maybe not but
maybe not Pippin
I want more episodes on Phil I'm
fascinated by Phil yeah I still keep Rob
okay so we'll say I'll say Rob right
where I'm in okay I'm and I get I
completely take back whatever the [ __ ] I
said about not one to see any other
characters that's fine I still find
Jordans would be the most interesting
one but Rodman is the most fascinating
one of the most fascinating human being
and human beings in history this is
unbelievable so I'm looking at this guy
I'm like there is no version of him now
some people said Kanye was that you that
said Kanye know some people who said
Kanye and I find it interesting Kanye
might have done the opposite version of
what Rodman did so like Rodman pushed
back against the stereotypes of
masculinity by by going like gay with it
and Kanye is pushing them back against
the stereotypes of blackness in America
by going may be conservative or Magga
with it right you're still rejecting
what you're not allowed to be in an
effort to be free and if you like look
at a lot of Kanye's language like I want
to be able to do whatever I want I want
to have that ability to be free I want
to do these it like Rodman said that a
lot - yeah right and he needed that
liberation he needed that leash you need
that extra long leash it was interesting
that Madonna was the one that was like
got it out of him yeah she's like son
Madonna's like white Erykah Badu think
about it Erykah Badu got to what every
good guy and flip there asked what was
the outcast dude dressed nor recess yeah
dressed normal - Erykah Badu got him
common came out of my [ __ ] accordion
but common had this weird ass out
Electric Circus as well he's oh yeah
Erykah Badu got [ __ ] you up [ __ ] at
Real Talk absolutely